what's happening you Savages Uncle Joey
here welcome to the checkin it's Tuesday
the 23rd of January I got to talk to you
for minute guys remember the days when
you could have sex in the morning
afternoon late at night and four times
here you were a Savage remember those
days you didn't give a [__] things may
have slowed down with age but thank God
for blueo you're saying Joy what are you
torturing me for blue is a unique online
service that delivers the same AC of
ingredients as Viagra Calis and
Levitra I thought Levitra was a heart
medicine but who gives a [__] all these
ingredients but a chewable tablet at a
fraction of the cost you can take the
tablets any time of the day so you can
plant ahead or pop one whenever you bump
into a victim by mistake you know what
I'm saying listen these things are great
they come in individual pouches you can
put them in your wallet just don't sit
on it and uh you know you meet somebody
you bump to your wife your girlfriend
you're at a bar you want to get the
party started you want to give her a
stab in the bathroom you or ask for some
water you pop a pill and within 15
minutes you know you're doing your thing
the best part about blue chew is it's
all done online no talking to no [__]
doctor you don't got to wait online at
some [__] bum Pharmacy everything
that you're going to need is right there
at your doorstep in a discret package
the mail man won't know it is your mom
won't know what it is Grandma won't know
what it is even the victim won't know
what it is blue Chu wants you to have
better sex Discovery options at
blu.com chew it and do it Jack and
listen it's Tuesday we got a special
deal for the checkin listeners try blue
free I'm promising you all these [__]
things you're like Joey how am I gonna
give Mama stabbing for free because this
is Uncle Joey baby I'm giving you blue
Chu for free all you gotta do is pay $5
for shipping that's it that's blu.com
code Joey to receive your first month on
the arm
again that's blu.com promo code
Joey and get your party started get your
freak on you can bet you can put on some
eyebrows and a cape whatever turn you
want and now without further Ado let's
see what the hell Lee's doing turn off
your TVs run for your lives it's over
they didn't put you on this planet just
to give up if Uncle Joey could do it I
could rule the world that's what you got
to be thinking welcome back
[Music]
to what up turkey
NE turkey NE godamn it Tip Top [__] M go
ready to rock here what are you doing
you know what Athena's kids call me what
I swear I swear to God mashed potato
tits okay what are you gonna do you
gotta turn them into heart potatoes now
you know what I'm saying it's
Tuesday it's Tuesday the 20 [__]
third Le you gotta get to those kettle
bells again that's it that walking [__]
is good but it doesn't you know it's to
get the fat off not to you know you got
to start throwing some weights around
it's time
yeah it's it's time for that what's the
hot black chick that shakes her ass you
know the chick for right now you could
join for a dollar and a dollar for a
month oh Megan the stallion or something
yeah might go see Megan mother nature
mother mother whatever the [__] she
calls herself go over there for a dollar
lift some weights do some bench presses
do some push-ups and
[__] what are you GNA
do I don't have mashed potato titties
but they're sagging a little bit like I
had a kid
you know it's like a [__] like it's like
a cat but they're not pointy at least
they're not pointy I continue to keep
some muscle under the tissue there by
doing [__] slant uh when I go to the
gym once a week I go to one gym and then
the other when I go to the other one I
do bench presses uh you know on a
[__] whatever on an angle and then I
do them minus and then I do pullovers
just to keep everything tight but that
ain't enough I got to go get some
Mexican f [__] uh pills or some [__]
like that so be 220 Tip Top M goo you
know what I'm saying you need that Swiss
Chris Alisa was telling us about Swiss
Chris thing that made you [__] yeah that
that another [__] lunatic with
another [__] suggestion how was
Nashville
Tennessee [__] really cool like a the
city itself was just like I'm not a
music person I know that sounds weird I
don't dislike it but it's just not
something I care about but it was just
cool to see like like I like they look
like they seem like me a little bit like
they were just you know doing bar show
some of them were doing cover yeah yeah
that
twoo that two trust me there were guys
in in cut off tank tops in seven degree
weather but um it was just a really fun
we it was just cool that like people
came to see like came to my show like it
was like I love opening for people but
it was just really like meant a lot that
people would come and and do that and it
wasn't any like it was very cool for me
but it wasn't anything like glamorous or
and we didn't sell a ton of tickets it
was like the the coldest it's ever been
there and they had got eight inches of
snow but it was just so awesome it was
for the experience and then the question
is that you gotta ask yourself when
you're a comedian from one to five years
one of the things I forgot to
do that you overlook is the question of
what did you learn tonight but when you
get upset about bombing or having a bad
set you don't think you learned anything
but you really [__] did if you're
honest with yourself you're gonna come
out and tell me the microphone didn't
work or the sound system but the guy
behind you got a standing
ovation right so you all the well the
guy before me pulled the rabbit out of
his hat out of his ass so then you got
to pull two rabbits out of your ass you
gotta outdo the guy in front of you you
know what I'm saying well ab and I was
thinking I thought a lot about that this
weekend because like the first night was
good I I had a like I would say B minus
set people were happy I did fine but I
noticed the second night like the energy
in the room was just better and like I
like I fed off of it and I need to do a
better job of like creating that energy
if it's not already there which is
something like I think you were very
good at is just like like making energy
like I'm I'm I'm getting okay like if
it's there I can feed off of it but it's
hard to create it to get energy in the
beginning of a set you got to go off
your set and you really got to pick up
steam and have confidence with saying it
because if you fall flat now you're
working for
minus right those first two you know
those first that first minute it's so
weird how kill Tony's a minute I've been
thinking about that what can an open mic
do in a minute he could do a
lot he could do a [__] lot in a
minute because an in a minute you can
make an introduction so special that
when you get off they want
more it's so [__] weird how you have
to but I didn't look at it like that
then so that's how you have to look at
it you know what I'm gonna go up there
and make them one more how do I do that
so all those little contests and little
things are planned out situations it's
like going to Jiu-Jitsu and they say
today we're not going to roll you're
going to start with a guy in your back
with a hook in and all he has to to do
his clothes what are you going to do
from there working from there and it's
called situational training you know and
that's the same thing in comedy you have
situational training so Friday
nights I hate Friday [__] nights
really yeah for
comedy okay I'm gonna tell you
why you got out of work at
5: you drove to your
mother's you took a shower you got
dressed you ate something with her you
gave her the solitary cards you ran to
Athen now you have to drop Athena's two
children off and then go do your show
right okay yeah go watch the show at the
Wilbur
Theater you get there at [__] 10: to
8 you walk in you sit down and you're
huffing and you're
puffing you're huffing and you're
puffing you're trying to catch yourself
and all a sudden 10 minutes in you
realize
[__] I'm [__]
tired right yeah okay you know it take
young guys you know when I was [__]
30 I could [__] leave work at 6 and
be there at 7 and you're ready to go but
people overdo themselves
sometimes and they get there and
something's not right the Air's not
working you know there's always a lot of
stuff that you can't control but you
have to go up there summarize it control
it and then work with what you got oh
you only got one [__] hand all right
use the other hand you
know is a v i can't break them all down
because we didn't plan to have this chat
but right it's just so weird sadly I got
the whole day to myself I mow the lawn
when the kids are at F football I eat
Mama's monkey I [__] have a few
drinks I I go out to dinner with some
friends we're all in a great mood now we
go see Lee
sayat bye bye the yeah I got tomorrow I
could drink a little bit I'm staying at
the hotel right down the block so I
could walk it's a better feeling they're
more loose how many other people that
come to a how many other 250 people that
go to a Friday show have to work
Saturday more not many like I would sit
there sometimes on Friday early show and
go out to take pictures and I go where
the [__] are the people they don't give
a [__] about your picture they got to go
to work on Saturday they got okay they
got to go pick up the kid and go to work
on [__] Saturday morning they got to
drop the kid off at the mother-in-law is
at 7:30 because yeah God knows what
people have on this schedule you as a
comedian you have to entertain them to
take them off that
schedule they just pay you to take them
away from their life for an hour when
they get the bill for the night it
brings them back you know at the they
dro the check 200 you
know yeah I I it's crazy to hear you
talk about that because it's I don't
really know like this like the
headlining thing is
completely like foreign to me I have no
idea what to expect I felt like I was
nervous like my flight got canceled on
Thursday because of the snow so I was I
was like freaking out about that I was
worried about if the show is going to
get cancelled because I talked to the
booker who was nice but he was like
listen man they don't have plows down
here so like the entire every road is
ice like the the parking to The Venue
was ice and so like up until up until
the day of the show I didn't know if the
show was going to
happen it was just crazy what you were
in the same boat as the people coming to
see you on Friday night yeah yeah and
it's just the fact that anyone like
especially in like a place like
Nashville I love doing my favorite place
right now to do shows are cities where
there's not much to do cuz like they're
fun crowds and like a lot of people show
up but like the there's so much to do in
that Nashville the fact that the 35
people came is like amazing to me and
like it was a small venue it was like a
50 to a 75 fet room but it was
just so cool and like the crowd was cool
the guy who uh may or may not have given
some like acid in the past showed up
with his wife from North Hollywood G ask
you something how crazy was that when we
bought a Bo a box of sugar cubes and we
putting acid on the sugar cubes in the
office
dude at a point there wasn't even sugar
cubes you just dropped it into my
mouth that's right that's
right you had all these sugar cubes we
didn't even use them oh my God every
time I go into the mouse would eat
one one of the sugar cubes yeah remember
we ended up throwing them out we we did
the hit acid like in four sugar cubes
now I had 96 of them just sitting there
like bumps on a log and [__] what about
all those because we all we used to get
those stars but they would give us like
six or seven brownies that tasted
terrible so we never ate them and like
at the end we moved out we had like 30
bags of like moldy brownies that were
two years old those brownies were so
[__] bad and those joints from the
weed stores we had about a hundred of
those the free joints oh yeah it's like
sandpaper they give you all the weeds
and the stems and the [__] dust on
the counter it's a [__] nightmare
damn we left when you said that to me
the other night was like liquid acid
what's he talking about I'm like oh [__]
oh yeah I that was just like the start
of
it dude this guy brought like six
different kinds of weed and some like
mushrooms and I like I'm oh yeah I'm
mushrooms [__] suuck I had a little we
split we you split them and then I gave
I didn't want to fly home with them what
why not what's going to happen you put
them in your [__] what do you mean
what's gonna happen are you serious
yeah you put them in your sh paranoid
what paranoid you don't think they know
about shaving kits you don't have a lock
on your shaving kit yes you do you put
on the dirty you put it on the dirty
underwear I travel with 4 five8 on me
different weed just in case I get stuck
on the island yeah that's because TSA
likes you they know you you TSA don't
know me I separate no they
don't they do you pack it up good you
cover it you get some Rolling Papers
some lighters you bring a lighter in
your jacket even though they don't want
lighters on the plane you always bring a
lighter just in case the plane crashes
how they going to find you you know what
I'm saying just pat you down huh yeah
they pat you down but they always Pat me
down yeah you well I got metal in my
knee so now it stops me to and then they
gra metal under there yeah I got a
[__] metal foot all right stop
bothering me there's metal in my knee I
gotta redo you see the stitches all
right got a redo yeah I gotta redo you
wanna you want to see the
stitches so yeah now that's why you can
bring stuff on like it's my knee I
established early on that I was not
gonna go to a [__] town
weedless There's no way it's too much to
me it's too much to my comedy there's no
way I'm going to a I I used to travel
into towns with no Coke because I could
always find a a bum [__] coke dealer
but I can't count on the weed that I
smoke in every state so before we have a
misunderstanding and I do buy an ounce
and it's not what it is it wasn't grown
in California it was in my cousin grew
it in Arizona but it was supposed to be
Cal I don't want to hear that [__] I
just bring the best weed with me this
week when I went to Austin I brought
four different reefers With Me ge you
not nervous at all huh you don't get
nervous no they're for your health there
you know no they're not see you say this
stuff like you could say it to the
police and they would let you go you're
like we established that I don't go
weedless no one established that what do
you
mean
La they don't they're not worried about
the [__] you know they're not worried
about [__] a the weed you br they're
worried about the bomb and your gun and
the electronic battery that might light
under the [__] plane on fire so don't
every those dogs I've been next to those
dogs with a pound of weed [__]
Boogaloo pills the whole thing and those
dogs are [__] can wag their tail and
like they want to be my buddy they're
not there for [__] reefer and for
[__] Baloo pills but the one day they
bring the one who is I'm gonna be there
I I get so [__] paranoid nah you'll
be fine the dog barks just tell them
[__] you're Jewish dogs been barking
you since the beginning of time you know
what I'm
saying German Shepherds and Jews don't
get along that's why they
invent to hold the Jews against the wall
and bark at
them and Jews are in the corner we'll
give you my pastrami sandwich oh
no I speaking of what did you think of
those the
tunnels what tunnels the one in the city
yeah they're disturbing they it's very
disturbing you know i' I heard different
reports some people said they were
storing kids down there you know to
[__] molest them like ep's Island
some people said they were putting
hookers there you know they would left
over kids from [__] Epstein's Island
so they were going to put them down
there and hold them up they turn adults
didn't let them out I don't [__] know
Lee just the fact that the Jews paciic
Jews I love them to death but they're
some creepy [__]
they they've taken over a town where I
live here called Jackson right like on
Saturdays I just go through to see them
walk the temple and the rush and [__]
like they got diarrhea with those gum
shoe that detective gum shoe that they
have with that black [__] Cape with
that they they haven't washed in years
no head and shoulders those [__]
tassels the dangling [__] dust on the
jacket they're hysterical but they
they're
perverts they're perverts you you ever
see their wives oh you have to be a
pervert to marry those women they like
make them marry each other or something
because I don't know about those women
they wear those little shoes and [__]
like that Dutch
ladies a jersey I got those cion Jersey
they're not [__] around
Jack I I was just there was just a video
I saw today of like this prostitute in
New York talking about that about like a
lot of her customers were htic people
not all of them but like they just they
like not they come in a little cap and
they put it right back in the head like
no that's why they go bald because they
got sperm on the circle of their head
there oh that's
they whack off into that little
cap are you talking about the Yuma like
the little small one or the big one the
little one the small
one holy [__] come inside the that's why
you never find DNA on those
[__] they come inside the
yamaka oh and then they put it on their
bald head yep no they put it on they
start with putting it on hair but the
acid from the sperm Burns through the
you know with all that pickle juice they
ate a lot of pickle
seeds I did show [__] Rogan the uh
the [__] crackhead toss oh yeah what
did he think we put it on during the
[__] fight companion how was your
time down
there honestly yeah really good nice
dude except for the no [__] sleep at
night without the fan I forgot to bring
my little [__] Boy Scout fan with me
and I can't that noise and I was up both
nights till like 4 five in the [__]
morning spinning around but how was
Austin it was an
experience it was great to see those
guys I hadn't seen them I hadn't seen
Brendan and Eddy since the
pandemic wow it's been that long yeah
since we all left you know they are what
they are they were the little family we
had in La you know and it was great to
see
them uh the the [__] fight companion
was awesome you know my podcast with Joe
again it's Friday it's 4 in the
afternoon we're both tired you
know yeah I didn't get to watch the
fight companion because but I I saw the
clip of you guys dancing with the
smelling salts oh my God you had some
moves dude I I like were those your old
moves you think you're dealing with old
moves they're new moves I got bunch of
new moves
I get dance this is a new move no that's
John Travolta I had to throw it in there
out of respect you know what I'm saying
it's it's [__] it's Molestia massuse
month
so I wanted to do a little shout out dry
January yeah it's dry
January uh [__] M your massuse month M
molesta masseuse month so I know
Travolta is on there on a tear right now
hey rub this little thing under my nut
you know what I'm
saying
holy [__] but that's it's that's fun
that you got to like do you think any of
the of the reason you couldn't sleep is
like you were just kind of like pumped
up from like your two days
like no there was something going on
because I was sweating a lot at night
even though the air was
on there was something going on ah I
came maybe I had Co and didn't know
it maybe it's another form of Co because
dog the sweatshirt that I wore on
Saturday night to sleep
when I woke up it was a light hooded
sweatshirt I had no t-shirt underneath I
don't want to wake up to piss in the
middle night and it's too cold to walk
to the
bathroom Okay when I woke up [__]
Saturday morning you thought like I had
been running a marathon for four hours I
put the thing in a baggie and I got home
the bag was downstairs and when I opened
it up to put in the laundry my wife was
walking by and I go feel this
and she was like Joey what Happ I go D I
don't know the blanket I it was a gray
[__] hotel I'm not GNA name Dr you
know Rogan takes care you yeah the
blankets must have been those high level
thermal blankets it was like being in a
sa I would pee in come back and I
couldn't lay in my spot I thought I
pissed a bed I was drenched I hate when
that [__]
happens you get back in the bed and it's
like you're laying on a funeral [__] you
know freezing a death you're like why
the [__] am I freezing why not just take
the sweatshirt off and leave it on the
bed in case you got
up what because couldn't that be while
you were sweating as you were wearing a
sweatshirt to bed no because it was cold
so I didn't have I knew if I got up in
the middle of night the sweat I was cold
with the [__] sweatshirt in that room
I had the [__] addir down to 60 with
the fan on high that [__] dog I
was blowing smoke out of there I thought
I was in The Exorcist of so cold there's
a great Hotel so it went down to 60 I
remember going to see the computer and I
had to put a [__] jacket on to sit by
the computer at night just to check
something out to see what time the
airline was leaving or you know when you
get back to the hotel the internet would
go down i' have to reset it like I'd
have to log in again you know I'd freeze
to death I go like what the [__] is this
I'm sitting there with a hooded
sweatshirt and a winter jacket on but
Austin was cold anyway Lee really yeah
it was [__] freezing in Nashville it
was when I landed it was humid and I had
a heart attack at the airport when I
walked off on that ramp it was so
[__] humid that humidity must have
gone in my lungs I started sweating Prof
fucious it was the humidity problem oh
damn oh yeah it was still humid in
January yeah it was like I couldn't walk
the baggage
claim it was [__] a rough little walk
I had to stop and make believe I was
talking on the phone people were walking
around me what's the matter with him I'm
like you know so I got the bug b baggage
claim and then on the way back I had no
problems with nothing I only slept two
hours on Saturday night I left for the
airport at
6:15 got to the airport the Salt Lake
was open like a
[__] oh yeah you got barbecue
for breakfast you bet you ask I got a I
got a two eggs with some
brisket dude I didn't even you said me a
picture of some barbecue you got this
weekend dog Rogan took me to some place
and he ordered the ribs I didn't order
that I couldn't eat that
right but the uh I ordered the brisket
with the smoked turkey and beans it was
[__] delicious it's so weird you move
to like Boston New York and your friends
tell you about this barbecue place and
you go there and you go there and and
you eat it and you go yeah it's good you
know or it's like being in LA and
somebody goes joeey you got to try this
pizzas just like New York and you go
over there and you eat it and you're
like yeah it's okay and then you come
here for something and you got a piece
of Peach and you go oh no whatever the
[__] I was eating out there I wasused
it's the same thing as soon as I been
into barbecue there's a place here my
wife gets brisket from I really like the
baked beans with the bris the B the
burnt brisket in it
yeah the burned ends but dog once y went
down there and tasted that brisket it
couldn't even it wouldn't even hold on
to the fork it was crumbling it was
[__] it spectacular remember bad
Barbecue in Austin is better than good
barbecue in New
York and bad Pizza in New York is better
than good pizza in La you can't [__]
lose I'm sure Rogan didn't take you to a
bad place which Place whatever place you
got barbecue this time yeah that's where
he took me well I'm saying it wasn't a
bad place it was a good place no no it
was a good place we went to do stem
cells I shot in my knees I did a stem
cell IV did see a difference not yet
it's only been three days I'm a little
sore still I hit the bag a little today
but I'm I can't work out the whole week
okay walk
so I could stand in front of the bag and
just throw punches and sweat a little
bit put some [__] music on and get
the party started or get some more of
those we I dog I I don't play around
with smelling salts I don't know what
they're about I only put them in my nose
I'm about to faint and I don't even have
them at home people put them in my nose
when I pass out in the dentist office
and [__] like that that's the first time
I snorted out of a vitamin container
people in America are losing their
[__] mind but I guess bodybuilders
use them uh strength uh powerlifting use
him apparently ComEd Josh Potter does it
too when I opened for Josh he pulled him
out and I don't know how you were
sniffing at the clip I saw I had you
sniffing it for like 30 seconds who did
you just not smell it you who you I I
was smelling it slowly I could take it
because when I wake when I pass out they
just don't do this to me they put them
under my nose they put one in each nose
when I pass out when I pass out I go
deep into the murky Waters that's why I
don't like [__]
going and give him blood sometime I
gotta go get blood this
week that sucks and and you pass out
that they have to wake you up with
smelling salts I knew you would pass out
but I thought you would wake right back
up it hasn't been years since they had
to do the smelling salt but oh thank God
it was smelling salt heavy
duty because they gave me one one time
and I fainted when I smelled it and
they're like this [__] on a
different
level wait you fainted they woke you up
with smelling salt and then you smell
smelling salt and pain again again and
they put two of them in my nose they
were laughing when I woke
up and I remember talking with the
smelling salt in my nose and they were
like that is [__] crazy I didn't know
was smelling salt I didn't two them
together is this like just because of
like of the cocaine like why do you
think you like doesn't affect you cuz I
[__] fainted so many times that I you
know I just got used to the smell of
ammonia like that in my nose [__] those
things like I would take like one little
thing and it would like knock my head
back the first time I did it knocked my
head back but then I got used I saw that
yeah first time I did it it was powerful
it hit my lungs I could feel it in my
nut sack tingling like [__] somebody
put acid in there but you know what man
we had a good time I got to see my
friends and now I come back and my
mission is a little
clear okay but on what you want to do
this year yeah
yeah now you I know like you did the
podcast Friday but did you think about
doing standup out there uh I was
considering it for Friday night but I
didn't hear from everybody
so I was very uh I don't know Friday
night I was pretty [__]
tired right you know Friday night I was
I had just gotten up early I didn't
sleep the night before so at 6:00 Eddie
wasn't coming in until like
8:30 so at 600 I got some Cuban food I
took an uba to get Cuban food which is
pretty good place called
Habana okay and then I went back to the
hotel and I started watching [__]
Rambo
8 and I never heard from Eddie till
about 11 and Eddie had gone to the club
and he said nobody was down there no
Tony hinchcliff got there late so he
came home so I didn't feel that bad and
then
Saturday we were shoo you know we went
to dinner at 700 and then we shot that
at
9: and we were there till one you know
there's no audience at
one right oh yeah it's fact
so and did you do stand up at all last
week before you left yeah yeah I went
down to Uncle Vinnie's Wednesday
night tomorrow night go to Sam's Club
but my daughter's got some or tonight I
was going to go to Sam's Club but I had
a my daughter's got a recital at 6:30
she playing the [__]
drums you know oh [__] that's cool yeah
she's been playing them for years in the
school B since the third grade or
something yeah she joined in the third
grade Tomar she's doing the drums and
the [__]
triangle so if you don't know so yeah
I'm gonna go over at 6:30 if I get out
of there early and they don't want to do
nothing afterward then maybe I'll take a
ride some where else around here that
cuz Sam's like an hour from
here yeah yeah the uh the dojo I'm
excited to I'm going out there in a
couple weeks that'd be really cool if
you I mean it it's just an open mic it's
just an open mic guys that's fine are
you but are you enjoying it still oh
yeah it's it's great to do listen what
I'm doing it's a plan and if it doesn't
work then you move on to the next
chapter of your life but this is how I
need to do it for right now not rushing
I'm not booking dates none of that [__]
no I'm just I wanted to see how it was
going no just keep getting on stage
having a good time laughing giggling
coming up with
material you know like I said the thing
I missed the most wasn't the stand up it
was the creating my mind needed to
create
again you know I got no more stories to
tell you know I have to do something
different
so this is
the that's that's awesome dude I'm just
happy that like you're you're enjoying
it it's seems I didn't hear from any of
those auditions last
week three aition I knew I went to the
producers on one row but I never heard
from them and again I was sitting there
today and I go wow that's weird and I go
you know what they got a better plan for
me everything happens for a reason I'm
not going to get upset I worked hard on
those
auditions so I had to you know cuz it
was for the same people so I had to wear
three costumes and hide myself a little
more I you know but what are you going
to do it just get you better for the
next time this is I wouldn't had this
attitude when I first got that he take a
personal go to the store and snort an
ounce of coke now it's like you didn't
get it no big deal you watch the show
the episode sucks you're like thank
God [__]
favor and like has it ever happened like
that you waited you know a couple weeks
a month or two to get to hear back about
auditions or they usually pretty quick
this is like a Law and Order type show
they shoot these the schedule if you
don't hear from them in four days they
went to somebody else because they start
shooting you know 10 days then they take
10 days off those one hour dramas they
shoot 10 days so but maybe they won't
call me till day eight who know you know
listen you wake up every morning you try
your best for that debt that's the
that's if that's all you could could do
that's all you could [__]
do yeah I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad
you're enjoying it and not getting too
caught up in things it's really crazy
that there's a standup page here and one
of the guys on there asked you know he
goes it's Monday you probably got on
stage this weekend what did you learn
and I go I used to ask leave that all
the time no matter how high we were when
we did the Ice House any gig together on
the way home
I'd ask you and Eric what' you learn
tonight you know I want you to think
about what you learned so that stays in
your mind then when you go home you
write something different and I was
sitting there today and I'm like
wow where did I learn that from and I
had to think for a minute and I thought
of you because you once told me you had
a couple different podcast going and
you're like these guys can't get it
together and they're professionals and
they have degrees and [__] all this
money but the only guy that's consistent
is a felon you know and I remember when
I I was doing comedy about three years I
met this comic named Rick
Karns the reason why we attracted to
each other is because he was crazy like
me gamble drugs you know and just love
getting on planes and doing comedy
anywhere he would do any [__] gig he
was very
funny he was one of those guys that was
funny 100% of the time because he was
just naturally funny you know and when I
moved back to Boulder in
94 you know I was very fortunate I got
to work with him a lot and I got to work
with another master of writing Todd
Jordan Todd Jordan was very professional
he was the HBO comic of the
Year oh [__] I I remember the name but I
didn't know he'd won that yeah he was he
was a special right did I
do uh on the other hand Rick had came in
fourth in San Francisco comedy
competition that year he was very
hot but at the same time he was very
crazy Rick is [__] 100% crazy and
100%
heart I haven't spoken to him since the
pandemic started because he called me up
when I moved him he wanted a loan and
I'm like I'm not worth it he just didn't
want a small loan he wanted a big
[__] loan I'm like I don't have that
number I just bought a house all my
[__] we didn't have it Lee you know
right he got mad at me and I've been
thinking about him ever since that you
know I mean we all go through different
things he ended up getting the money and
it worked out for him and stuff and he's
doing well now God bless him but Rick
was [__] crazy so let's say we had a
gig at 8
o'clock in
Wyoming right right he would [__]
like either take a bus to me and I would
meet him like in Boulder at
5 and the first stop was at a liquor
store oh okay he get a gatorade he get a
big Gatorade and a bottle of vodka right
there on the road he throw the [__]
Gatorade out he'd leave like two ounces
of Gatorade and he poured a whole bottle
of [__] VOD in there and we drink it
on the way up then we stop and get
another one and somebody always brought
powder to the show and it was just but
on the way home no matter how [__]
high we were he'd always go what did you
learn tonight and I'd sit there like an
awe because I didn't think I learned
anything but at the end of the day you
did learn and you learned a ton of
things not to talk to the manager not
you know you just learn little things
but what did you learn on stage and even
though listen when you kill you learn
and when you bomb you learn that's
what's great about [__] comedy that
you learn both ways you're gonna learn
something about
yourself you know you're gonna learn
something about yourself you know I felt
really bad for Joe KY a couple weeks ago
because again it was people criticizing
him that didn't know the art of comy and
then somebody made a joke about that he
flipped on the writers he said hey I
didn't write these jokes you
know if that was any other situation
that's a very funny
line right it's as a standup it's very
funny it's very funny but on TV and in
front of those Mucky mucks it's not a
funny line and then the Press ran with
it and whatever but it's really
funny he didn't write that like he wrote
that on the spot because he wasn't doing
well and he was trying to get out of it
he was trying to get out of it you know
any comic could see that he did great
considering the fact of where he was he
had just forgotten where he was we
perform for you know we work for years
and you build an audience and every time
you do a show it's your [__]
audience when you step yeah it's it's
it's very weird so when you step out
that's why I [__] up but I wanted to
feel that that before I shot the Netflix
special I was going to the fourth wall
and I was going to Flappers I should
have been at the store in
hindsight but I want wanted
to work
differently it was a different I didn't
want people to see me I had a bunch of
reasons why I forgot why I brought this
up for the story but it was just uh I
don't
know you you were talking about like
what you
learned okay
andur I learned that I I should have
done it at the store I should have
worked on my special at the store store
sharpening it even though they were an
audience that was familiar with me the
reason why I was going to Flappers in
the fourth war was to go in front of an
audience that wasn't familiar to me I
would do the fourth wall first to get
the wording down and then I would go to
Flappers in front of a show that had
nothing to do with me it could be a
Polish show and I'd go
there right and i' go up and out of the
30 people in the audience one guy would
go Uncle Joey the rest didn't know me
from [__] Adam and that's enjoyable
because you could really test your
material right I can see that and that
and that's you were talking about Joe
Coy and his experience he felt bad for
him because of what happened to him at
the Golden Globes and guess what even
though he's a 10 time millionaire even
though he sold out the garden he learned
something that
night he learned himself that night so
whether it's good or whether it's bad
you're going to learn something and Joe
always been doing comedy what 25 years
he's a [__]
veteran have you ever had it cuz that
happened to me a little bit this weekend
I did I had a better show and we talked
about what days they were but my better
show was in front of people who didn't
know
me it was kind of
strange Lee because you sold
it when I would go up in front of an
audience that knew me I could use both
podcasts I go on the podcast with the
church and Rogan I had so F of to to my
realm it's like living in Seattle and
then moving to California you you lose
10 minutes of
material because you're talking about
Seattle a geological site a [__] you
know geological a [__] Street Corner
a certain restaurant you went in front
of a mall what goes on up at that
[__] airport ctac whatever so you
lose material it's the same with that
it's the same kind of concept that's why
I said to you know keep writing it's so
important to after your show to keep
writing and before your show to tune up
your set I don't really think you should
start you know it's exercise it always
do some writing excises write about a
situation in your first CL first grade I
don't give a [__] you know I don't give
a [__] I used to write the weirdest
stuff just to warm up so I wouldn't sit
there with a pen in my mouth
[__] that's an interesting way to start
okay you said that before to start
writing why am I gonna sit there with a
pen in my mouth for 45 [__] minutes
doodling Athena calls my wife calls mom
calls and you're sitting there the whole
time with a
[__] 45 minutes right time you get to
the hour your hour 15
deadline you started getting hot the
last
hour but for that
but if you got there right off the bat
opened it up and just went into a story
any story I don't give a [__] you know
you don't how long do you want to sit
there with it and maybe that story now
let's let's turn that
funny and you start scratching words out
and putting words in and blah blah blah
blah Lee It's [__]
amazing it's really [__]
amazing and it's I I listened to what
you talk we talked about it a week or
two ago about watching yourself and I
really don't like doing it but I've been
trying to do it I I have a phone that I
record on now and I noticed for some
reason the Friday show I just had my
hand on the stool for like a good
portion like and it looked like not like
like I was scared but it didn't look as
confident as like if I don't know why I
was touching
it it was just like and I it was just
something I don't really I know that's
where I noticed my energy was down when
I was watching it cuz listening to it it
was wasn't as
noticeable you learn a lot from tape
it's tough to
watch but you'll improve a lot
faster I really believe that if you look
at I mean listen I don't want you to go
to Mike's [__] Snack Shack and tape
your o micat and get upset with you you
opening for Josh you did what you did on
Friday and Saturday you know that's when
it's worth it for you so you get an
honest
an honest reaction from the audience and
it's you working under
pressure yeah when I go to an open mic
do you think I I I sit here and right
before the open mic I go there to
actually put a gun to my head to make me
say [__] to make my mind work instead
of why sit there with the pen in your
mouth it's also like the how long did it
take you to get comfortable to
do 45 to an
hour to go from 25 to an
hour what do you
mean I
noticed that I was focusing a lot on my
set list and the Order of Things similar
to when I started doing 20 instead of 10
all right let's now want to do 2020
let's focus your set down to a 30 minute
set before we can do
45 you going to do 30 minutes the
education you got from that was actually
doing the 45 and it's not
easy nothing bothers me more than when
somebody goes I did 45 last week yeah at
a [__] bar and you're not a headliner
no you could call these club Owners and
tell you're a headliner and somewhere
along the line you're gonna crash
because you don't have your feet under
you trust me what I'm telling you I've
seen it a thousand times and it it might
be so devastating at the third year that
you don't recover from it those are the
guys that quit right there yeah after
they bomb for 45 yeah no they they go up
and think they're G to do 45 and they go
into the wrong room and they eat a bag
of dicks and they don't know how to get
themselves out of it that's 45 minutes
to get yourself out of if I MC and I
bomb I only got 10 minutes to learn my
lesson if I feature and I bomb I got 25
minutes to learn my lesson if I headline
and on bomb you might as well [__]
trade place to Jesus it's the same
amount of time they're going to kill you
in a [__] hour
so this is why I don't like that I want
people to understand and guess what this
is one of the things I never did because
I knew headlining like being a feature
like being a
host is an art all three of them are
distinctive [__] arts and yeah you're
young now you're a new comic that
they're going to tell you how to read
these ads and they actually [__] with
you when you it messes with your
material but there's one day you're
gonna figure out how to read the ads in
your
jokes oh as a host as a
host right you know yeah it's they're
not gonna sound like
ads you know coming next month chichin
Chang the month after that Tony tanuja
the month after that Joey de nobody
cares they're drinking they're drinking
why you hitting them with three dates
let's focus on chich and Chong we'll
come back next week and [__] vote on
Jimmy tooch but for right now let's
focus on [__] chich and Chong all
right you just learn [__] you just learn
[__] from being there these little
things that you just pick up you know so
when you attack a MC spot the owners of
the clubs are going to be there you
usually featur Lee but tonight's no feat
feure spot but the guy that runs the
club he's got 18 clubs he's going to be
there tonight this is like stealing for
you you don't go well I'm going to
feature I'm usually an MC shut your
mouth and make the best of what you got
you an MC tonight you got 10 minutes to
rock right so I suggest you you write
that [__] set out you got a minute to
greet them and welcome them maybe go
into some crowd work maybe maybe are you
pregnant thank happy birthday and then
from there bam at the 7 minute Mark stop
and do do a [__] whatever ads he
wants you to quickly like it's part of
your
material and then you attack this the
last part of your set like a [__]
manic like they just gave you [__]
smelling salts up to your [__] and
then you wrap up the mic you got that
last minute now and now is when you go
I'm gonna bring up the next guy but
don't forget next week is chichin Chang
two weeks from now is Lee sayat blah
blah blah blah blah blah coming to the
stage the very funny leas I
at now the guy the features also have to
look at his style what is my style is my
style high energy is it low paste if
it's low paced if I'm high
energy and you're slow Pac you're
actually G to do I don't know 30 minutes
of material in 30
minutes I'm going to do 45 5 minutes of
material and 30
minutes just joke joke joke just breathe
watch your next watch your next
Target unleash watch your next Target
unleash talk to them let them catch
their breath bam ended one last
time so it's all a strategy
Lee yeah I know that's what I'm hoping
what I'm looking forward to improving
because I don't have I I do try to like
I have a set list and I think it flows
okay but it's just I thought about you
you because I would ask you sometimes
like there was a difference between you
doing 20 minutes at the store and doing
a headlining like you would slow them
down a little bit and that's what you
told me like you would be like they
can't I couldn't do that for an hour
straight it's an hour so you have to
slow it down I only got 45 minutes of
material so I know I could Rock 45 heavy
what I'm praying for
if there something to
happen is I'm praying for some chick to
say I love licking ass or you know some
crazy chick in the audience and then you
run with
it you know you're praying for and you
will get it because your materal you
struggle running with it you what do you
like because I'm just thinking when
you're saying run with it like crowd
work or reacting to something like I can
react to something and go into material
reacting completely improvised it's not
that I don't do it but it's not very
long it's like two minutes
okay did you did you ever die doing that
like was did or were you always good at
that that seems like something you
probably were pretty good at I the
problem I started improvising by mistake
I was a house MC at a [__] restaurant
and I had to be there every Tuesday and
the first two rows were the same [__]
people every week they came in to get
the prime rib for
$15.99 right so about two months I was
in my beginning stages I said I can't
keep doing this with the same material
so I would write the whole week I would
come up with five new minutes every week
then seven new minutes and I remember
there was a time I was doing 10 and it
was because I was doing crowd
work and I got into a bad habit with
crowd work and then I got into the worst
habit I moved to New
York and this is and this is the town of
hey where you from oh you a truck driver
from the Bronx what do you sell ovens
you know [__] it just went on and on
and on and then I went somewhere and a
club corrected me and they said you
can't do that here and he goes I know
you can do it but I don't want you to do
it because I want you to work on your
material for the next time you come
here wow and then you get really good
you know how to improvise and take it
back to your material and improvise and
take it back to your material and
improvise so I always like when people
learn how to improvise like once you get
standup down for two years and you're
comfortable go off the limb a little bit
and learn that realm and then you after
a while you fine your whatever for years
I thought I was funnier if I didn't
write and went up there guess what I I
had 40% good
sets W and when you at that point were
you taking like an improvise something
and turning it into a joke or you were
just no I was just to improvise go up
there and talk to the
audience W that's crazy even to me
having 40% good sets doing that is
pretty [__] high no you want to be at
80 90% you want one bomb out of 10 oh
well yeah but with material yeah but if
you going up there with no plan and just
being funny off the cuff and an in front
of an audience well I was doing a lot of
that [__] at the at the Seattle
Underground on Mondays and Tuesdays but
then when I wanted to work Harvey's and
all those other clubs they were like God
do material man and there's some people
who are really really really good at it
but you'll see after a while
that I don't know I mean Jeff Ross is
good at it so I could be really
wrong you know Hollywood just doesn't
react to it after a while you know not
Hollywood but just there's too many
people doing it I don't want you to ever
get in the habit of it but I want you to
know what you're doing real quick let me
talk to these people about better help
I'll be right back Le hey Uncle Joey
here listen the checkin is brought to
you by better help you're saying Joey
what's better help better help is an
online therapy that's very helpful for
celebrating your strengths working
through your weaknesses and learning to
set boundaries and Tak an action in your
life I don't know what that means all I
know is I was [__] up and I contacted
blue uh better help and they put me with
some woman and she taught me coping
skills I don't know nothing about
weaknesses I don't know nothing about
learning to set boundaries all I know is
that you know I was [__] out there
where the buses don't run and they
brought me back in listen better help is
tremendous why because it's completely
online so you could talk to your
therapist through video chat over the
phone or by message whatever works for
you for me I spoke what I want to see
who I'm talking to what is this some bar
and some I don't even know just fill out
a brief questionnaire you get match with
a licensed therapist and you could
switch therapist at any time for no
additional charge that you know listen
better help is here to help you they're
a great service I believe in I'm
150% why because you know when I got
here I was getting flashbacks in Vietnam
I was you know people would chck I don't
know I don't know but anyway don't worry
about me right now I'm back because of
better help so celebrate the progress
you've already made again I don't know
what they're talking about visit
betterhelp.com
dezod to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
Diaz trust me betterhelp is gonna help
you get there you know how I know
because they took care of Uncle Joey and
now without further
Ado back to Lis sayette all right see I
don't even know what we're talking about
Le sorry I interrupt you but I had to
tell these beautiful people about better
help and how they get a little help
every once in a while uh you know [__]
happens talk to people absolutely um you
were talking about improvising but like
I was I was also I wanted to ask you I
don't know if if if you've ever dealt
with this like the wrong reaction to
your jokes like some guy was very nice
he came both nights but I'm I'm kind of
self-deprecating is my style and like he
was
like he like he would laugh but he would
also go a a
lot and it was like a it's not something
I I knew how to deal
with I don't know if anyone's ever like
had a weird reaction like the wrong not
the reaction you were looking for to
your joke was it his face or was he
talking he he said it a couple times he
wasn't rude but he was just like he that
was his reaction I think he just like
liked me no he was [__] rude
he was rude I'm not going to sit there
and analyze each of your [__] jokes
he was rude and next time don't pay him
no [__] mind don't even look at the
[__] look at him one time and
then look the [__] away from because
those people go out to ruin your night
that's some [__] snobby dude that's
some snobby dude that nobody invited him
to dick not even his mother invited him
on for dinner because he's so [__]
annoying so now he's going out of his
way to break somebody balls who's trying
to do something with their
life you know it's it's like when I shot
the the thing in
Chicago that [__] kid kick him in the
[__] face I mean it was it was
horrible he was hammered he didn't not
want to be there and he was jealous that
his girlfriend wanted to be there do she
was 30 years younger than me I'm not GNA
hit on her and she didn't want she just
liked that whole group there was a ton
of girls I spoke to on the road that
came with their boyfriends and they were
the primary fan it wasn't a lot it was a
lot of that's why I always brought a
woman to open for me because I had a lot
of PE guys that would come a lot of
women would buy tickets for their
boyfriends and I got three three guys
going up I got the whole room filled
with women so I would have a woman go up
before me so they could get something
too right but every once a while it's a
woman who wants a come she watches Rogan
she watches whatever she knows what's
going on and she wants to hang out you
know and yeah but I remember that couple
fighting in your special that was that's
I can't believe that happened it was
horrible it was [__]
horrible and there was a point where I
was ready to [__] kick him I could
not
believe that you work so hard all your
life to get a special for somebody to
pay attention and tonight is the night
some [__] drunk
[__] wants to come and ruin your
night because she bought tickets for
herself but he didn't trust her so he
said I want to come why would you want
to come if you don't like them well
because and they come I learned that
when Rogan was on Fear Factor that was
one of the openers I saw that a lot it
was a table of girls and there'd be one
husband that [__] loser and he'd be
sitting there glaring at you glaring at
you hating on you hating on you but
what' you do instead of [__] getting
caught up you just looked into the
audience and made them laugh their ass
off so he hated you even more you want
his wife to go isn't he funny and for
him to
goo so that's how you work those dudes
don't even look at them do your show be
as funny as can be and after a while if
you pay him attention they're going to
keep doing that right's talking to you
you don't talk back to them they're
gonna eventually
stop you there was one time that I like
I saw you deal with like like there was
it's probably like the best dealing with
a Heckler I've ever seen it
wasn't and it was similar like I we were
in Denver and after every joke you did
this moment went yeah and you didn't
react to
it like she she was not hiding it she
would laugh but then she would like just
do yeah like after every
joke I don't think he said anything I
don't think you said one one word to her
I was like Jesus Christ how does he
handle that let them let listen first
off when you're young you want to battle
the audience
remember right a bad habit to get
into unless the guy throws something at
you a knife a
bottle listen they I like the shoes you
know
what if you get into with them you're
gonna get hot and the audience didn't
pay that to see you get mad or to see
you shut I shut down a Heckler for 20
minutes and say everything you know I
don't go to your job and knock the dick
out of your you know it's the same [__]
so I decid one day don't say nothing to
them they go away on their own and after
a while the laugh to do or and after a
while security just throws him out
they're either drunk I saw one time when
Joe was on Fear Factor we did
Breer and do you remember the door man
at BR was a real muscular guy I think so
headed guy that had was bald and he
looked like a [__]
door I don't know if it was BR or Irvine
was it La Hoya no no it was an in
problem okay it was an in problem he was
a big guy you could tell I mean this guy
probably ate a box of steroids a day you
know he even had a heart attack years
later he lived but he lost all the
weight he came to an improv and he was
walking with a cane and mean it was bad
oh [__] yeah he was [__] big at one
time a little too big and he was
tough and I opened up it's probably
online God damn
it even when I turn the phone off I get
these [__] things I don't understand
I'll figure it out for you yeah I gotta
turn it off on the computer and now all
day I don't hear from these [__]
losers and now at 8 o'clock at night
they want to [__] be my friend get
the [__] out of here stupid
[__] so when I got up there
this guy was already being a problem he
was being a problem with Ari was up
there Ari was opening and I was the
feature in fact if you go online you'll
find the video it's up some somebody
taped it and they attacked me for going
off on the guy and it was probably that
tape that made me go I get it
now instead of argue with them and then
I would see other Comics get into an
argument with and it just shuts the show
down right it does it's awkward it
conflicts the show now you got to work
from zero again now I'm in the bottom of
the grave and I got to dig myself up to
you know it's it's you know it's
whatever the expression you use
but I remember I went off on the [__]
guy and finally Joe went up and he went
after Joe and that's when it got ugly I
mean the security guard came and choked
him and he was yelling police brutality
and they beat him up outside and as I
walked outside the wife looked at me she
goes this happened like six weeks ago at
a different comedy show then why would
you bring to another [__] comedy
show Jesus Christ he goes to different
that that's one thing I I normally don't
get like Heckle heckled but I don't like
that it's just a crazy thing some Comics
invite it and I don't get it like that's
like my my worst nightmare I don't want
to get heckled look everybody's
different everybody's looking for a
different every like I said what did you
learn
tonight what did you learn tonight I
learned that I after a Heckler and he
left and I'm better than you know think
about is this business or is this a
[__] repap there a thing called
whatever that challenge what's it called
they used to do it at the store where
you tear each other up upstairs on
Tuesday night roast battle roast battle
go a roast
battle I actually had that written down
have you ever done like roasting jokes
no no okay no I think it's always been
[__] stupid I don't want to get into
a argument with nobody
because they're going to take it
somewhere and that I'm going to take it
somewhere and it's not going to be fun
for either for him or for me maybe I'll
say something to get under his skin or
he'll say something to get under my skin
because there's a thin line you know
what I'm saying there's like a thin and
then somewhere along the I remember
years ago they were doing a series about
that it was it was it was
[__]
Ralph ra if you look at early Ralphie he
did a series oh okay remember I think
one of the girls jod went off on Ari
because of his nose and [__] I didn't
want to do it I didn't get it I don't
like roasting celebrities not that
Comedy Central always ask me but I don't
I didn't like doing that [__] no roast I
like standup I'm a standup [__]
comic you
know that's it it's that
simple and that's what you define as
your
as you're getting into the business you
know I was when I did the podcast with
Joe I told him I said there's going to
be a time when I just want to do standup
again there's not going to be any
podcast there's not going to be any
acting for like a year or two I just
wanna write and perform 10 minutes a
week 20 minutes a week just to see what
it was like to put all your attention
into stand up you know with the social
media and the videos and everything
somewhere along and I told Joe even with
the sponsors somewhere along the line
you forget what you got into this for
this is the reason why years
ago 30 years
ago Bill Hicks went after [__] uh Jay
Leno and he said that Jay Leno should
get a gun and shoot him stick it in his
mouth and shoot himself and blow the
back of his brains on the NBC
Peacock you know and you think about
that I remember going to Houston one
time and a young bunch of young Comics
were like go [__] that man you do
commercials
like I got an
addiction I gotta addtion money at a100
doll a
set you know I don't have a rich mommy
and daddy like you [__] driving
up here with new jeeps and [__] you know
it's it's different for everybody I
didn't do commercials because I wanted
to I did commercials because they
[__] paid and I got insurance out of
it you know I I really enjoyed doing
movies and TV certain projects I really
enjoy the last time
you when was the last time you did only
stand
up
1997 [__] so from 91 to 97 I didn't get
head shots till
95 never just focused just focused on
standup writing stage writing stage
writing stage there was no nothing else
there was no
distractions and that's why when I'm
writing this book about standup I have
to make it
clear that you could take all the
pictures with funny comics that you want
you go to all the award
shows you could you know you could do
all the shortcuts you want but at the
end of the day all they're going to give
a [__] about is the one thing because
once that gets up then everything else
gets
noticed you know and some people have a
lot of success with videos and standup
you know Eric alesandro is great with
that stuff I love Eric's videos have you
watched Eric alesandro's videos I I
don't know if I
have he makes the best videos any
comedian could [__] make that end up
a big time director someday comedy is
just a stepping stone for him if he
doesn't Direct in 10 years he's going to
be in 15 years I call he directs a big
movie that's going to be his path he
makes these little videos that are
tremendous and he's getting popularity
from him and he writes and he performs
and he goes on tour you know but it's
some people I don't want them to get I
see a bunch of comedians at my level a
little that came like five or six years
after
me they're trying to go to award shows
they hire a
publicist and they go to all these uh
Latino women and this and that
look that gets you nothing because the
people that go to those things are all
looking for the same thing a [__]
handout so that but if that's what you
think your career should be
doing what would you rather do go do
three sets in LA or go go to an award
show and sit there and dream of being
next to Brad Pit you know and hopefully
get into the back or go to a party yeah
you could pay your publicist 3,000 a
month and she get you those you're not
gonna get into Elton John's party right
but to some kid that plays you know I
don't know one of these [__] terrible
shows and he's like the eighth lead
he'll have a party and they'll let you
in there you know it's just so weird
what it became what I saw the
waste you know I enjoyed just doing
standup but I enjoyed podcasting I
really [__] didn't you know now it's
going somewhere different all of a
sudden you know it's it's changing it's
going a shorter podcast it's you know so
it's very interesting even for you and
me sometimes I sit there and I go it was
completely different when we
started it was so different you know and
now the people got in it and they just I
don't know it's weird now everybody's
got a podcast and I ain't mad at nobody
it's the way it is but it was a
different Market when we got in there
was only 10 drug dealers on the block
now there's dealers
everywhere there was only eight not all
of them huh I was gonna say not all of
them but like some of the biggest
podcasts are by famous like there were
no like the most famous person who had a
podcast was Kevin Smith when we started
yeah like and and now [__] bit like
like there's so many podcasts hosted by
movie
stars and it's just this week I'm in
Vancouver at the house of comedy with
Josh he's filming a special oh [__] yeah
I'm going I'm doing shows on Friday he
he's filming on Saturday but I'm going
up on Friday and Saturday at the house
of comedy in you have shows on Friday
yeah and Josh is filming a special on
Saturday so make sure you go to that one
two shows I think so yeah good good see
that's the other thing now Comics have
freedom again with specials everybody
wanted a Netflix special everybody
wasn't going to get a Netflix special
you know a lot of people didn't and it
stopped people from growing they're like
I got to shoot a special I'm waiting for
Netflix shoot your own [__] break it
down to 7 Minute routines you know it
doesn't have to be [__] that's what
great now you could shoot one of these
with a [__] iPhone straight on you
connect yourself to a mic get your buddy
to come down with the soundboard you
wanted to sound I wanted to sound like
Richard Pryor one of his albums or
[__] you know something by Paul
Mooney early you know I wanted to sound
like a red fox I don't want it to sound
like everybody makes their [__] sound
today because then you're not different
you're the same [__] you
know it's a different world my friends
it is and then you going up on Wednesday
you think if if her uh recital gets over
well Tuesday is the recital tonight got
it okay tonight it's 6:30 I think it
starts at
7 you know we're not going to get out
until 8:30 and then 8:30 if I drive an
hour it's I'm walking up to go do a set
at an open mic and bump people or
whatever I don't want to do that I want
to get there early talk to some of the
comics you know I don't want to get
there in the rush like I'm Johnny gobba
and just you know like to go on stage no
I came here to [__] call
my man I love it buddy it was good to
talk to you it was good to talk to you
man and we'll uh we'll talk tonight or
tomorrow absolutely talk later all right
have a good night thank you brother
thank you for watching the show tonight
to check in with Uncle [__] Joey and
Lisa yet see you [__] suckers next week
and now for the ad of the
[Music]
week what's happening you Savages Uncle
Joey here welcome to the checkin it's
Tuesday the 23rd of January I gotta talk
to you for a minute guys remember the
days when you could have sex in the
morning afternoon late at night and four
times here you were a Savage remember
those days you didn't give a [__] things
may have slowed down with age but thank
God for blue you're saying Joy what are
you torturing me for blue is a unique
online service that delivers the same AC
ingredients as Viagra Calis and
Levitra I thought Levitra was a heart
medicine but who gives a [__] all these
ingredients but a chewable tablet at a
fraction of the cost you can take the
tablets any time of the day so you can
plan ahead or pop one whenever you bump
into a victim by mistake you know what
I'm saying listen these things are great
they come in individual pouches you can
put them in your wallet just don't sit
on it and uh you know you meet somebody
you bump into your wife your girlfriend
you're at a bar you want to get the
party started you want to give your stab
in the bathroom you all ask for some
water you pop a pill and within 15
minutes you know you're doing your thing
the best part about blue chew is it's
all done online no talking to no [__]
doctor you don't got to wait online at
some [__] bum Pharmacy everything
that you're going to need is right there
at your doorstep in a discret package
the maale man won't know what it is your
mom won't know what it is Grandma won't
know what it is even the victim won't
know what it is blue wants you to have
better sex discover options at
blue.com chew it and do it Jack and
listen it's Tuesday we got a special
deal for the check-in listeners try blue
free I'm promising you all these [__]
things you're like Joey how am I gonna
give Mama stabbing for free because this
is Uncle Joey baby I'm giving you blue
Chu for free all you got to do is pay $5
for shipping that's it that's
blue.com code Joey to receive your first
month on the arm
again that's
blue.com promo code
Joey and get your party started get your
freak on you get you can put on some
eyebrows and a cape whatever turn you
want and now without further Ado let's
see what the hell Lee's doing